good morning believe nation my name is
Evan Carmichael my one word is believe
and I believe that entrepreneurs will
solve all of the major problems of the
world
so today's message is be decisive over
to you and a win tour I try and be
decisive I try and even had it or how
I'm doing I try to be decisive because I
think it's very comforting and
reassuring and important to the people
they work with you to feel that whoever
is in charge knows what they're doing
and knows what they're thinking and that
if it's a yes it's a yes and it's a no
it's a no I mean I don't think of myself
as a boss I mean I I think of myself as
someone who's giving direction and
guidance and vice versa so I don't know
if I agree about the advice of trying to
be decisive even if you don't know what
you're doing but if you agree with the
fact that people want to work for a
leader who knows what they're up to what
they're trying to accomplish that
there's a clear mission a clear path
nobody wants to work for a leader who's
all over the place who says one thing
one day one thing another day nobody
wants to work for that person so if you
aren't on Twitter and you're building up
a team then you have to be really
careful about the direction that you
give them and have confidence in the
direction that you're going the way that
I do it I think works pretty well least
for me is one being really clear on the
mission like here's what we're trying to
do here's what I'm trying to accomplish
this is going to happen we're going to
make this big thing happen but the
specifics of how to get there may change
not every project will work out and
that's okay you're going to have little
bumps and bruises and failures along the
way lots of them lots of little bumps
and bruises and failures and hopefully
you keep the size of them you know how
big the impact is to a minimum but
you're trying out lots of them because
you need to go through that pain to get
to the success but even though those
little things didn't work out you're
decisive and clear and understand the
big picture of where you're going and
you believe it in your heart that it's
going to happen if the leader does not
have confidence and what's happening
nobody underneath you is going to have
confidence either if you are all
concerned that this is not going to work
you can bet that that's going to spread
like wildfire all the way down your
organization you need to believe hardest
believe most of anybody in your company
but this big thing that you're trying to
accomplish is possible again the how to
accomplish it will change you need to
know the specifics but you have to have
that point the guiding light the
destination here's what we are trying to
accomplish here's the wall we're trying
to fight and it's 100% winnable that
confidence will inspire people to follow
you and will encourage them to push
beyond their comfort zone bring more
creativity bring more of themselves
because they believe in what you believe
so the question of the day today is I'm
curious what is the big thing that you
are trying to accomplish that you
believe in your heart is possible even
though others around you might think is
a little crazy leave it down in the
comments below I'm super curious by note
I also want to give a quick shout out to
Jennifer steyr Jennifer thank you so
much for picking up a copy of my book
your one word it really really means a
lot to me and I hope you're enjoying the
week so thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is and I'll see
you again tomorrow morning for another
shot of espresso
[Music]
vision making is a process right the
question is what filters are you using
to make decisions are you making
decisions based on the financial rewards
are you making decisions based on how
easy the work will be I mean I remember
in college you know they would give you
this book where they all the students
would rate the classes and they would
rate things like how easy the class was
and how you know how much you they liked
the professor and you know the first
year I picked all my classes based on
workload and I picked everything a low
workload you know and pretty bored
didn't work very hard which is fine but
nothing was dynamic and nothing really
excited me and I thank goodness learned
that and so the second year I picked all
my classes by professor rating
regardless of the workload so every
class I had I had these dynamic amazing
incredible human beings passing on their
knowledge and you were excited to work
hard for them you know and so again what
the question is what if the filters were
using and so if you're only chasing the
mighty dollar then you will have jobs
that'll pay you a little more than the
last but are you enjoying yourself and I
talked to a guy recently who was in he
didn't bad shape like he really hates
his life and he's really depressed he
doesn't know what to do and so we were
going through all his old jobs you know
and I said give me a job that you've
loved and he hadn't every single job
he's chosen out of college he picked
because of the the money and if
something offered him more somewhere
else he took it you know regardless and
and and and the amazing thing is he
plateaued because if you're only chasing
the result if you're only chasing the
thing that makes it easy right then
eventually you will get bored or they'll
get bored of you right and you plateau
in other words chasing the own mighty
dollar if that's your only thing it
eventually flattens out whereas if
you're chasing the thing that excites
you the human beings to be around the
work that excites you the stuff that you
know you know you you can get passionate
about you know the the irony is you'll
actually make way way more right because
you're excited and they appreciate your
excitement and they reward your
excitement and you're better at your
work because you want to work harder and
all of that stuff you don't have to
strain to work harder so decision making
is simply a matter of filters you know
and so I've made decisions in my life
that I would rather be happy than right
I'd rather do good then then get rich
and and so the decisions I make put me
in positions where when I leave any
engagement when I leave any meeting I
feel that I've contributed right rare
are the times anymore where you walk
arguing just think of the money just
think of the money think of the money
you know
I because that doesn't feel nice and and
the experience I have I don't enjoy
traveling to them and I don't enjoy
traveling home we have an amazing
experience I'm looking forward to
getting there and I'm excited when I
leave you know so it's just decision
make decision making is just a matter of
what filters you use and if you're if
you're good about keeping those filters
up and clear then then make your
decision I don't judge anybody by how if
they choose to use different filters
these are just the filters I choose to
live my life you know not right or wrong
just those are my decisions
you know that's my filter this is
something I learned in Asia because
obviously when you take a CEO job and a
company you learn a lot you learn a lot
one of the thing I learned particularly
in Japan that's from time to time making
quick decision is going to hurt the
execution of the decision because I do
what you want when you make a decision
what you want you want to transform
reality you don't want to make a
decision for the sake of making a
decision you make a decision because you
want something to change so your goal is
the thing changed that's your goal so
now the question is when should you make
the decision in order to make sure that
this thing has changed in the fastest
period of time so from time to time you
have to wait to make the decision
because you're preparing people to
execute from time to time you need to
make the decision very early from time
to time a little bit late but when I say
decision is means capacity to take the
decision at the appropriate time because
at the end of the day what you need is
reality changes that's that sugar